hi everybody my name is Adam carpenter
as you just heard Audie talked about
there's a lot of ways developers are
considering diversifying their revenue
via Todd's i AP subscriptions for those
of you who are already firmly invested
in the IA p space i'm gonna try to go a
little bit deeper and talk about some of
the signs and the patterns that you can
see in your own data which can
potentially help you identify there's
opportunities to grow your business so
one of the ways that always like to look
and think about the whole notion of
revenue and how it all interrelates is
something that we call the revenue tree
or some people call the revenue funnel
this is kind of a very important view
because it shows how all the core
components fit together and feed upwards
to generate the revenue that we see on a
daily basis and if you're not familiar
with this graph to get the top level
metric you'd multiply the two below it
except in the case the dotted line boxes
where you'd add them together and now
when I think about a lot of the core
monetization metrics generally speaking
I like to divide them into two different
categories the first the daily buyer
percentage I always like to think of
that as the primary monetization metric
since you for thinking about the
effectiveness and your ability to
monetize your users it's almost always
better to go for breath it's
significantly safer to try and get a
buck out of everybody versus being
overly reliant on your whales in
contrast I'd like to think of average
revenue per paying user average
transaction value and transactions per
buyer its secondary monetization
measures because while they're
critically important what they really
measure is your ability to extract value
from users who have already chosen to
pay and one of the jokes I used to kind
of make when I was on the developers
side and still kind of make it a Google
Play
give me virtually any game tell me the
double average revenue per paying user I
could easily do that and tank the
business at the same time because it's
always so easy to squeeze players and
squeeze players and you're lifting up
your average revenue per paying user but
your buyer conversion is plummeting
and so in terms of topics today I'm
going to kind of walk through the
revenue tree and the first thing I want
to do is take a look at top-line revenue
health and show you some of the ways
that I like to monitor revenue
performance that help me understand how
a game is doing the next we're going to
take a look at buyer percentage and in
particular talk about some ways to think
about increasing the returning buyers
and especially the frequency at which
users are paying within a month and
finally we move on to talking about the
secondary metrics and there I'm going to
primarily try to give you some food for
thought about some ways that you can
potentially change your games that could
help improve the metrics in that space
so to kick off with top-line revenue one
of the major ways that we're always
driving it one of the major ways that
we're maximizing your performance
LiveOps
most of you are already probably doing
it if not you're probably considering it
and it's such an integral part of
driving our businesses of stimulating
demand but LiveOps isn't this one
monolithic thing and the way that I like
to think of it is breaking it out into
supply-side sales or demand side events
and I like this notion because it helps
to think about the balance between the
two so supply side sales that's the
injection of discounted assets into the
economy the ways that you can give users
additional value for each of the dollars
that they're paying in contrast demand
side events this is when we're running
the tournaments the weekend challenges
the competitive engagements all the ways
that we get players to engage more
significantly ideally draining down
they're an asset balance and creating
the greater potential for those users to
pay in an interval a Shinto is
critically important in order to ensure
that you have a very balanced and
healthy game economy and ensure revenue
is ultimately strong here's a couple
examples of vastly different ways that
developers like to run their live ops in
the case of the blue line the one on the
left this is a perfect example of a
developer who likes to run the
occasional roughly once per month NASA
sale what you can see is they generate a
significant amount of revenue during
that period but then on a normal week by
week basis you're seeing this is the
start of a live ops revenue spikes
trends down that's the off day of the
week when it's not running and then it
starts again and so you kind of have
this constant pattern on a week by week
basis the green one this is an example
of a developer who's trying to run live
ops virtually every day they're
balancing their supply side and their
demand side and what they're doing is
creating a much tighter band and it's a
very interesting perspective and an
interesting prote because what the
developers fundamentally trying to
endure we're trying to ensure is that
every day is appealing every single day
some of their users are perceiving good
value in the game and being willing to
opening up their wallets and paying and
so a great way to kind of think about
this is what's the right strategy what's
the best strategy unfortunately I can't
really tell you that one is inherently
better than the other it depends on your
development team what your skill sets
are what your game is but one of the
strategies that you can use to
understand how your LiveOps performing
is a monitoring technique we call the
revenue heartbeat and what the revenue
heartbeat does in any given calendar
month calculate the minimum revenue day
the maximum revenue day and the average
revenue for the month and then if you
plot it over time you get a
visualization like what you see here and
ideally with the revenue heartbeat what
we're really trying to see is that the
min and the max they form a tight band
around the average that you don't see
any wild variations on a month-by-month
basis you don't see any divergence and
that is your average revenue is growing
you're seeing that the bands themselves
they're not inherently widening because
this ensures that you're stimulating the
right kind of demand on a day-by-day
basis and that your players are engaging
heavily and engaging consistently some
of the more negative patterns that you
would see these are shown here and I
really like point a as an example
because this is a wonderful case of a
game which in the month of March
they actually ran a massive sale but
what that sale resulted in was a pretty
significant hangover and so you can see
the spike but then the min fell off and
it actually resulted in a drop in the
average so while sales are inherently
good if you can't randomize the amount
of hangover the duration of it you can
run into results like this where your
revenue ends up being net negative for
the month when you compare to the month
before in contrast of that point be in
June this is actually a great example of
a developer who began tightening up
their economy during that particular
month they didn't run as many sales but
they were stimulating to demand and what
that was a very effective at doing was
getting users to drain their asset
balance down so there was more of the
need to pay because as we all know
Friday P games if users asset balance is
high what's the point of spending any
money but then you always run into
situations like you see with point C
here massive Black Friday sale not
enough demand afterwards so you see a
big spike but the men fell off again
this revenue heartbeat it's a really
wonderful way that you can actually
monitor understand the performance of
your game and get a good sense of the
effectiveness of the sales that you're
running and whether you're running
potentially too frequently there's also
some more advanced ways that you can
take a look at your revenue and one of
the ones I particularly like is
calculating the coefficient of variation
for your daily revenue across a month
for those of you who aren't familiar
with this calculation what it is is take
all the daily revenue within a month
calculate the standard deviation of it
and divide it by the mean what that will
give you is a measure of the variability
or volatility of your revenue in the
monta you can effectively think of it as
a percentage score and so it's really
useful for quantifying LiveOps
performance and additionally what we've
actually found is that correlation or
coefficient of variation it actually
correlates to revenue growth and so what
I'm going to talk you through now is how
you can actually use this to understand
the potential for your games to grow
month over month and the kind of
optimizations and the values that you
should be looking for
this particular graph and I'll explain
it this is looking at the top 250 I ap
games between January 2017 and January
2018 and what we've done is looked at
their coefficient of variation by month
and we've put them all into buckets and
so what you can largely see is that a
majority of the games had a coefficient
of variation below 39% so there was some
volatility but there wasn't an extreme
amount where it gets really interesting
is we take coefficient of variation and
we look at which of these games had
month over month growth that's what we
see here the games with the lowest
coefficient of variations were much more
likely to see month over month growth
games with a coefficient of variation
between 10% and 19% so a month over
month growth about 56% of the time
in contrast games with a very high
volatility they saw month over month
growth less than half of the time so
it's kind of an important thing to
consider how volatile is the revenue in
your game how volatile the sales and is
it actually going to be healthy for you
and is there an opportunity to try and
optimize your live ops cadence balance
the demand and supply side events and
decrease that volatility because the end
of the day volatility is not the ideal
scenario that we're looking for consider
a game where you're running regular
weekly sales and events or you're
running major tentpole of sales at the
beginning of the month how easy is it
for your users to figure out what their
pattern is and I'd figure out that well
they always run a major sale at the
beginning of the month
why should I ever spend money any other
time as soon as you start to create that
habit the expectation the anticipation
of your users about when the sales and
the events are going to occur this is
when you can start getting it to asset
hoarding situations because users know
when the sale is they spend as much
money as they possibly can afford during
that sale and then they ride those
discounted assets for as long as
possible
this results in things like spend
cannibalization because
users weren't gonna spend right before
the sale because they know it's coming
and all of these combined this is what
gives us the revenue hangovers that once
players have figured out the pattern
you're actually losing money when you
think about your swing you've run your
sail and the hang of your receipt you
afterwards so one of the ideas we always
like to talk about and I really
encourage you guys to think about this
it's what I call predictable
unpredictability and what I mean by that
is can you create scenarios and
situations in your game where users log
in expecting something good to happen
but they have no idea what that good
thing is can you get your users to
anticipate a good thing but they're not
going to fundamentally change your
behavior before it actually occurs it's
a pattern I used to use very effectively
on the developer side and I'd encourage
you to think about how predictable is
your game in terms of the events and is
there an opportunity to spice that up
make it so that players can are not
fundamentally changing their behavior
because they know what you're doing so
moving on from that one talk a little
bit about increasing your returning
buyers and I want to talk a lot about
the 80/20 rule how many of you guys are
familiar with us in games okay a few
yeah what the rule it's almost like an
industry name says is in a calendar
month the top 20% of payers contribute
80% of the revenue and we look at the
Google Play data it's actually largely
true when you look across the entire
ecosystem top 20% of payers pretty much
contribute about 80% of the revenue when
you look across each and every game but
I've always kind of thought like doesn't
seem inherently healthy it doesn't seem
like it's long-term sustainable and it
probably doesn't seem like what the
best-performing games out there are
doing and in fact they're actually not
this is the top 25 games on Google Play
during the month of April and what we
can actually see only six of these guys
got more than 80% of their revenue from
the top 20%
payors majority of them they were in the
low 70s three of them were in the 60s
two of the games in the top 25 they were
actually in the 50s so that the top 20%
of their payers only contributed about
53 55 percent of their revenue these top
games are getting money from a much more
diverse range of players and really want
to kind of drive that home because what
we're looking at here this is the top
100 games in the month of April and what
you can actually see as it rises the
further down the top charts you go the
more reliant these games are on their
top 20% of payers it's kind of important
to think about and think about where
does your game fall into the top charts
and how reliant are you on your top
layers and is there an opportunity to
actually broaden your base because I
really think this is a key concept that
the leading games on play they've got
the most distributed revenue and so how
can you take that as inspiration and
figure out opportunities for improving
and optimizing your games one of the
ways that actually I'd like to look at
it is taking monthly our pupu average
revenue per paying user and the number
of unique days users are paying in the
month and what I like to do is slice
into deciles and for anybody who's not
familiar what a decile is effectively we
take all the payers in a month we put
them into 10 buckets people who pay at
the most go in the first bucket people
get the second listing on the second
bucket and so on and what I'm going to
talk through in these slides this is an
example of a fairly typical action RPG
and what you can see is the top decile
the people who paid the most 579 dollars
on average in a month it's a pretty good
amount in the second-best isso 120
dollars a month and so this is kind of
falling into that 80/20 role this
example game most of their revenue is
coming from the highest paying users but
what about all of these guys 50 percent
of the monthly buyers in this example
game and this isn't a contrived example
this is a real example pay to less than
$10
is that an opportunity for growth or is
that just something we don't care about
because we only care about the highest
value users to me because I'm like the
ultimate growth mindset person I think
it's a real opportunity and in
particular if we actually take a look at
the number of unique days all of these
monthly buyers paid half of them only
paid on one single day how easy would it
be to get these guys and gals to pay
just one extra day out of the month
doesn't seem like it'd be that hard to
me to provide them with the right
compelling value proposition which
incentivizes them to open up their
wallets a second day and actually what
we've seen when we look across at
virtually every game and I'd really
encourage you guys to check this
yourselves for most of the game mostly
IP games somewhere between 40 and 60
percent of your monthly buyers are only
going to pay on one day and so what's
kind of the real opportunity here what
should we be focusing on and where can
we extract potentially the most value in
my mind it's taking a really focus on
those users who are only paying on one
day and again with this example game
what we see is 80% of these buyers who
only paid on one day they paid less than
$10 so this to me is just this huge
upside in this huge opportunity to go
after these users with very targeted
offers very targeted sales exceptional
compelling value proposition and get
them to open up their wallets because of
your game had 50% of the buyers who only
paid on one day and 80% of them paid
less than $10 think about if you can
convert half of them to paying another
$5 another $2 another $10 that seems
like a huge upside to me and it's one of
the great things because it's really
really sustainable and so what I really
encourage you to do in terms of
improving performance is think about
that value proposition think about how
you're communicating the value for money
to your users how compelling is it how
easy is it for your users to understand
what they're actually
getting I'd also encourage you to think
about your sales segmentation and
especially how you're presenting it to
users one of the things I've often seen
in games and above hasn't wondered about
this from a user psychology perspective
if I'm a low value user who occasionally
spends five dollars and a game runs a
major sale and I see $100 skew in the
game am I going to be excited about the
$5 offer you're giving me or am I going
to be upset seeing the major value
proposition given to high spenders and
I'm not gonna even gonna spend my five
because I know that my five won't let me
compete with the guys who are spending
100 so think about how you're segmenting
your users and how you're presenting
those offers and try to give users
offers that are targeted to their
personal spending habits and strongly
appeal to them another one that when I
think of or get you to think about is
daily deals and there's a becoming a lot
more popular but if you think about some
of the top games that are doing them are
they really communicating value well are
they communicating the concept of
scarcity well and are they really
communicating almost like aspirational
goals for making that purchase because I
think that the notion of daily deals is
extremely effective but it encourage you
guys to try and uplevel it and the last
one I'd encourage you to think about is
this notion of like a repeat buyers
bonus what can you effectively create
which motivates users to spend every
single week and I'll throw out one that
I've been rolling around what if your
game is assuming it let's say you have a
game that has XP in it what have you
created let's say a 10% XP bonus for
anyone who purchases during the week so
if you purchase any amount of money a
dollar even you get a 10% bonus for the
next seven days is that really gonna
hurt your game economy or is that going
to create a compelling reason for users
to purchase at any price point every
single week I think it's the latter
because I think that's an extremely
appealing benefit that users would get
plus of course the IEP that they'd be
purchasing and now the last thing I want
to talk about is optimizing secondary
metrics in here
I'm not going to have any strong advice
this is more of a food for a fault thing
say do you think there's some
opportunities for us to improve our
secondary metrics and where I want to
start off is kind of looking at core
metrics for like kind of the percentiles
for the secondary metrics across Google
Play and if we look at transactions per
buyer and this is across the top 250 I
ap games we see that on any given day
user who purchases make somewhere
between 1.5 and 1.9 transactions and
they're doing so at a price point of 850
to $25 and ultimately what this results
in is an average revenue per paying user
depending on the game of somewhere
between thirteen seventy and forty 450
that's a pretty significant amount but
oftentimes it's coming from a very small
set of users and so I think it's
something important to consider is
what's the relationship between all of
these metrics and is there opportunities
for improvement when we take a look at
how average transaction value on the
x-axis compares to average revenue per
paying user on the y-axis it's positive
it's linear if you can get users to
purchase at a higher price point you're
going to get more revenue out of them
obviously that was but I think the key
thing here is that given that the
transactions per buyer on a daily basis
were only one point five to one point
nine the primary driver for average
revenue per paying user it's coming from
an average transaction value in contrast
when we plot transactions per buyer on
the x-axis and average revenue per
paying user on the y-axis it's kind of
just noise we actually spent a decent
amount of time looking at cluster
analysis curve fitting and other options
like that could not figure out any
reliable pattern to predict what was
going on here and so this is one of
these areas where I think it's actually
more tied to a games design in a games
core economy and with one of the things
I'm starting to think about is how can
we actually leverage the game design to
bring more order to the chaos that is
this relationship
game design has always been like one of
my big things and B go way back I was
actually a systems designer for years in
game economy I have one of my other
loves and it's always figuring out how
do you create the right appeal on your
players how do you incentivize the right
kind of sync rates and what are the
improvement things that we can do
because if you think about that
transactions per buyer and encourage you
to think about this from the perspective
of your own game where do you fall in
this spectrum
are you below the twenty-fifth
percentile and if you are below the
twenty-fifth percentile how many assets
are you selling your game do you only
sell gems or only sell coins or only
sell credits and if you do what kind of
price points are you actually selling it
at because what I want you to consider
is that if you have a low number of
transactions per buyer and you're seeing
a lot of them being sold at very high
price points what's going to be that
velocity for money or if you effectively
created a scenario where users are
incentivized to buy the largest pack
possible because of the bonuses that are
on top of them and then they ride those
assets for as long as possible because
users know that they're going to spend
them eventually so there's no urgency to
buy on multiple times in contrast if
you're above the 75th percentile I think
the first question to ask is how many
assets are you selling if you're selling
two or more I think it's perfectly fine
I think you're in a really healthy range
if you're only selling one kind of asset
what impulses the simple spying decision
making are you actually creating in your
game have you created a scenario where
users are incentivized
to make a small number or a large number
of very small transactions each day $2
$2 $2 if you are I think there's a risk
that you're leaving some money on the
table because every time a user has to
make a decision about making a purchase
there's a chance that they'll stop and
so if you do have a case where a large
number of transactions are at very small
price points think about whether there's
an opportunity to give up so your users
instead of showing them $2 for X number
of gems give them a $2 offer and give
them a $5
for present them with two choices and
see if you can upsell them because at
the end of the day I really do think
that there's some opportunities to
optimize and improve this area but it's
fundamentally going to come down to you
guys the developers because each set of
games is different and so what I asked
you to encourage you to do is go back to
your development teams and ask questions
like what's your velocity of money how
many impulse purchases are players
making on each and every day
does your in-game incentivize asset
hoarding and in particular how's your
game economy designed is it a capex
economy where users are primarily
purchasing assets purchasing let's say
gems and spending them to get permanent
upgrades or is it more a case that users
are purchasing some sort of a consumable
asset coins credits and they're spending
them as part of their daily play and now
this is kind of like one of my views in
terms of growth in terms of how we build
our business and talk through all three
of these areas so just in the last
couple minutes I want to give you what I
see is the key takeaways I'm hoping
you'll take with you minimize volatility
because that's going to be the biggest
driver for revenue growth figure out how
your LiveOps performing how you're
balancing your supply and demand side
events and see if you can actually close
that volatility because what we've seen
from the top games on play the lower the
month the lower the month evolved or
daily volatility the more likely games
are to see month over month growth I
also want you to consider what's the
80/20 rule look like in your game how
much revenue are the top 20% of your
payers contributing and is there an
opportunity to diversify and broaden
your base to get users who are only
spending once per day or once per month
to spend a second time per month because
what we've seen from the top 25 games on
play they're significantly less reliant
on their whales than other games that
are further down the top charts and
finally just think about your secondary
metrics because we see that average
transaction value an average revenue per
paying user there's
strong correlation but there's not much
of a correlation no correlation at all
between transactions per buyer I don't
have a solution for this one but I think
with all the creative minds that are out
in the audience in all of your creative
teams I think one of you guys or many of
you guys can figure out a way to
actually improve this and optimize it to
better grow your business so I hope you
guys got some benefit out of this today
really appreciate your time here
[Applause]
[Music]